es ist eine der spannendsten fragen der
astronomie und die konnte jetzt endlich
beantwortet werden die rede ist von den
ersten riesigen supermassereichen
schwarzen löchern bei denen es sich um
gigantische objekte handelt die in sehr
kurzer zeit extreme mengen an materie
angehäuft haben doch wie konnten sie
sich so dermaßen schnell entwickeln
klicks um science-fiction hier gibt es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
diese hellen und sehr langlebigen
objekte des universums können selbst auf
die größten entfernung hin
im weltall nachgewiesen werden die rede
ist von quasaren dabei handelt es sich
um kerne von galaxien die besonders viel
radio strahlung aussenden konkret gesagt
in quasaren die kerne von aktiven
galaxien noch genauer formuliert sind
supermassereiche schwarze löcher mit
massen von mehr als einer milliarde
sondern in galaxien zentren hier strömt
gas und anderes material ein
und dabei heißt es sich stark auf und
strahlt deswegen extrem hell der
forschungsteams weltweit wissen noch
längst nicht alles über diese mysteriöse
basare
klar ist aber bereits einige hundert
millionen jahre nach dem urknall
existiert diese supermassereichen
schwarzen löcher das große rätsel der
astronomie lautet wie sind diese
gigantischen objekte so schnell
angewachsen und wie konnten sie zu ihrer
erstaunlichen größe kommen dazu
der astrophysiker emanuel farina die
anwesenheit dieser frühen monster mit
der milliarden fachen masse unserer
sonne ist ein großes rätsel der lösung
für dieses rätsel sind jetzt fachleute
des max planck instituts für astronomie
in heidelberg auf die schliche gekommen
dazu haben sie die umgebung sehr alter
quasare ins visier genommen diese
existierten bereits als das universum
lediglich eine milliarde jahre alt war
somit war das licht der nun untersuchten
objekte achtung 12,5 milliarden jahre
auf dem weg zu uns unterwegs oder anders
formuliert diese galaxien zeigen uns
dass universum zu einer zeit als es erst
eine milliarde jahre alt war
wow doch wie gelangen den fachleuten
dieser sehr tiefen blick ins universum
möglich wurde das durch das
charakteristische leuchten von
wasserstoffgas wolken im uv-licht dazu
schreibt das autorenteam in der
aktuellen studie als wahrscheinlichste
erklärung für das leuchtende gas
der mechanismus der fluss enz der
wasserstoff wandelt dabei die
energiereiche strahlung des quasars in
nicht mit einer bestimmten wellenlänge
um die sich durch ein glimmen bemerkbar
macht bei uns in den teleskopen auf der
erde sehen wir das leuchten als rotes
licht bedingt ist dass durch die große
entfernung und die damit verbundene
kosmische rotverschiebung die wiederum
wird durch die räumliche ausdehnung des
universums mit überlichtgeschwindigkeit
bewirkt denn raum kann sich tatsächlich
schneller als mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
aus denen beteiligt war der spektrograph
multi juni spektroskopie explorer news
am very large telescope vlt in chile
so gelang es dem forschungsteam außerdem
der räumlichen verteilung und der
geschwindigkeit des gases entlang der
sichtlinie auf die schliche zu kommen
und diese riesigen gaswolken sind das
futter für die supermassereichen
schwarzen löcher diese erstrecken sich
bis zu einer entfernung von rund 100
tausend lichtjahre vom zentrum der
jeweiligen galaxie mittlerweile wurden
31 objekte genauer untersucht und in
zwölf fällen gelang der nachweis von
sehr dichten und ausgedehnten
wasserstoff wolken diese sind graphit
aktiv an die byrds galaxien galaxien
gebunden und umhüllen diese für die
fachleute ist ganz klar die menge an gas
ist so ändern dass diese gaswolken als
speisekammer für die quasare dienen sie
haben also den supermassereichen
schwarzen löchern als futter gegeben
demnach werden die schwarzen löcher
durch das gras gefüttert das radial zu
den galaxien zentren strömt das sind
wirklich spektakuläre erkenntnisse
denn so nah sind wir den ersten quartal
bisher noch nie auf die spur gekommen
dazu im manual farina der an der studie
beteiligt war die entdeckung dieser
ausgedehnten wasserstoffgas wolken ist
ein wichtiger schritt hin zum
verständnis wie diese schwarzen löcher
innerhalb von wenigen hundert millionen
jahren seit den ersten sternen wachsen
konnten das forschungsteam aus
heidelberg feiert seine neuen
erkenntnisse jedenfalls sehr dennoch ist
auch klar dass die forschung zu den
ersten supermassereichen schwarzen
löchern noch am anfang steht was
passiert in einem schwarzen loch
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
doktor watson der kanal mit richtig
coolen tierisch aufwendigen videos also
unbedingt abonnieren bis dann bleibt
dran